secretary alejandro mayorkas says this
we're on pace to encounter more
individuals on the southwest border than
we have in the last 20 years
the situation we are currently facing is
a difficult one you think so
so what are the border communities
seeing on the ground let's bring in
sheriff mark lamb
from pinel uh arizona uh first off
sheriff
when people say this is bad as it's been
you've been doing this job
five years can you put it in perspective
oh yeah this is as bad as it's been i
mean this is worse than what it was on
the obama days and this
it was like the wild west out there in
the desert on the south end of our
county
and we're back to that again we can go
out almost every time we go out
we're finding 20 people last wednesday
we had 49
apprehensions in my county so this is
just like it was back in the obama days
probably worse and on target to be worse
so think about this sheriff
i know you do every day we don't you
know we're worried about coming into the
mall and encountering somebody
that's within six feet of us not wearing
a mask
are these uh illegal immigrants
traveling with rapid tests
no no they're not being tested you know
and now they're you know we got some
five page email telling us how it's not
a crisis and how uh
they're gonna do a better job of trying
to get these people tested but
look they're not being tested they're
coming in here with who knows what
um and then we're having to deal with
them in our counties and it's unfair
and at the same time we're telling
businesses and kids they can't go back
to school they can't open their
businesses
but we're we're opening our borders and
letting people come in unchecked it's
it's ridiculous to me
and just by the way let's have the
numbers back up your words right now
take a look at this in february over 100
441
uh in 2021 that's up up 28 from the
previous month
up 174 compared to february 2020
and the president of the united states
said there was a surge before him
in past years put it in perspective how
bad is that
you know what they want to do is
continue to do the blame game they want
to blame president trump
president trump never denied we had an
issue in a crisis on the southern border
we were trying to fix it building the
wall doing all these things
but now we've just we've sent a message
to the world that we have open borders
we're not stopping people
and and now we're paying the price for
it they're sending under company miners
the cartel knows what
our policies are that's why we're coming
together as sheriffs
i started an organization uh protect
america now you can check that out check
it out at protectamerinow
americannow.com where we're we're
fighting to protect our borders and our
communities you are and look at these
numbers in tucson
you're up 45 with uh unaccompanied
minors kids
in yuma up 104 single adult
encounters in tucson up 206 in yuma
324 and people come down they look or
they don't show up like president biden
has no plans to go down
but you have to live it every day and
living it every day
and having ignored has got to make
everything worse
it drives us crazy you know i've
extended the offer and i'll do it again
to any congressman or woman
or senator who wants to come down and
see this problem firsthand please come
down and see it so that you can vote
uh with actual knowledge of what's going
on because truly they're voting and
they're talking about this issue
and they don't know what they're talking
about and sheriff what bothers me so
much this is an american
is to see some of that barrier the fence
the wall built and the huge gaps
as if everyone was told drop your hammer
drop the tractor
and go home we paid for this already
and just be for pure political purposes
because senator joe biden voted for the
secure offense act it is not completed
they literally just told the crews to go
home i've talked to a lot of the workers
from one day to the next those people
lost their jobs those families were put
out of work
they stopped it and and you know what
the cartel knew that
and they just started busting people in
left and right
um they're 100 000 people is an extreme
amount of people
there is no way think about that if them
handling that amount of people on the
border especially unaccompanied minors
um and the cartel is making so much
money off it and let's not forget the
drugs
last week we had a 12 pound heroin
seizure
it's it's going sheriff keep fighting
we'll keep
we'll put keep the uh the sirens on and
hopefully someone will pay attention
sheriff mark lam thank you you got it